regenerative agriculture is a set of
farming practices that increase
biodiversity in soil organic matter
currently most agricultural practices
are devastating to biodiversity even
organic agriculture while not as bad
still does more harm than good
regenerative agriculture is a way to
reverse this trend to actually make a
positive impact on the land so what does
regenerative agriculture actually
involve answering this question is
actually pretty tricky because the
practices that work best largely depend
on the land that's being worked with so
the variety of different practices
border on infinity a bit more than this
video can cover however let's look at
three common forms that regenerative
agriculture can take the soil is full of
organisms which are helpful for plants
some convert soil nitrogen into a plant
usable form some bring water to the
plants that would otherwise be out of
reach others loosen and aerate the soil
increasing water absorption and allowing
plant roots to penetrate deeper when
soil is turned over by a machine
most of these organisms are killed so
the crops must rely on chemical
fertilizer which ends up leaching into
the water
central to no-till farming is to not do
that instead of tilling plant cover
crops whose roots break up the soil let
the worms aerate the soil and bring down
nutrients keep the soil covered with an
organic mulch which will break down over
time adding more organic matter to the
soil
from the release of methane to clearing
forests for pasture land cattle raising
is known for being very environmentally
destructive but this is not inherent to
grazing animals if the right practices
are put in place enormous amounts of
carbon can be sequestered into the
ground soil can be built an even
desertification can be reversed in a
matter of years here's how it works
the growth of grass tends to start slow
accelerate and slow down again this
middle area is where it accrues the most
biomass that most efficiently if it's
eaten before it gets to this point its
growth will never speed up this is what
happens with traditional pastured
animals they eat all the grass which
doesn't have the chance to grow back
fast enough before getting eaten again
and we have over grazing this leads to
soil erosion drought and desertification
but if the animals are kept in a tightly
packed herd like they used to be in
nature the grass has time to grow before
being eaten all that biomass in the
grass is carbon that comes from the air
not all the grass gets eaten however
some of it gets pooped on and trampled
which ends up creating the perfect
conditions for new topsoil to be built
this ends up happening incredibly
quickly this is one of the most complex
and location dependent practices there
are I will therefore be over
generalizing a bit it always starts with
observing a local forest and the
relationships between everything in it
the plants the animals the fungi that
landscape the soil the water and then
recreating these relationships in a way
that's just as ecologically resilient
but produces more food food forests are
often thought of as comprising seven
layers the root layer the ground cover
layer the herb layer the shrub layer the
low tree layer the high tree layer and
the vine layer every one of these layers
either produces some sort of food or
medicine or is in some way helpful to
the system as a whole the plants are
mostly perennials and include as many
native species as possible
these three examples of regenerative
agriculture plus all the rest of them
all have something in common
whereas in conventional agriculture you
seek to create as many of one thing as
possible in regenerative agriculture you
seek to create as many relationships
between things as possible you are one
of those things what sort of
relationship with the land do you want
to foster
[Music]